[Music]
on this wednesday night no mercy
for a mass murderer the toronto van
attacker guilty on all 26
counts he took lives and he didn't care
the judge's ruling
and the relief canada's coveted 19
vaccine
rollout the prime minister's more
optimistic timeline
and the next provinces to delay the
second dose
bidding wars and big profits why
canada's two most expensive housing
markets
just got hotter mystery in the air would
you hop on a flight
without knowing where it's going plus
risky rescue mission
imagine you're playing darts except the
dartboard is moving and you have to hit
bull's eyes and it's in the dark
a burning boat dozens of lives at stake
and a race against time
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a verdict in a horrific
case
of a mass murder in toronto nearly three
years after the driver of a van
deliberately slammed into pedestrians
on a busy sidewalk he has been found
guilty
of murdering these people 10 counts of
first-degree murder
and 16 counts of attempted murder it
happened april 23
2018 on toronto's yonge street the man
convicted today had rented a van and
plowed into pedestrians
the judge said he planned to kill as
many people as possible
one of those who survived is catherine
riddell
it's not closure and it's not like i'm
not happy i don't feel like dancing
but i feel like justice has been done
and
and it's a relief off my shoulders that
we have finally got this trial
done in her ruling today justice malloy
dismissed the defense argument
that the accused was not criminally
responsible saying he knew it was wrong
to kill people
he chose to commit the crimes anyway
because it was what he
really wanted to do this was the
exercise of free will she said by a
rational brain capable of choosing
between right and wrong
why did he do it the judge concludes
there were multiple factors but the
bottom line
he did it to become famous because of
that the judge did not name him in her
verdict today referring to him instead
as
john doe saying that media coverage is
exactly what this man sought from the
start
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
what was he thinking the act seemed
senseless
mindless yet it was also planned and
deliberate
from the moment an arrest was made and
for the next three years
questions revolved around the state of
mind of this mass murderer
i honestly don't know what i would say
the man who had nothing to say to the
families of the people he killed
turned to a defense claiming a mental
disorder caused by his autism
during a virtual trial psychiatrists
debated whether he was
criminally responsible in the end judge
anne maloy was persuaded
alec manassian made a rational choice to
kill
his attack on these 26 victims that day
was an act of a reasoning mind
notwithstanding its horrific nature she
said and notwithstanding that he has no
remorse for it
and no empathy for his victims the
verdict guilty of all 10 murder charges
and all 16 of attempted murder of those
injured
with first degree murder he faces a life
sentence with no eligibility for parole
for 25 years
for families of the victims an enormous
weight finally lifted
it's like you're holding your breath for
three years and you can finally breathe
rocco d'amico lost his daughter we still
we're always going to miss her
i don't know how you address to it kathy
riddell was run down that day and has no
memory of it
he can spend the rest of his life in
jail because he deserves it
i'm sorry he took he took lives and he
didn't care
a verdict other than guilty would have
shocked the legal community and most
canadians
the crown is pleased with her honors
thoughtful and reasonable verdict
and grateful for her honors careful
assessment of the evidence
the man responsible was told of the
verdict by his lawyer but boris
baitanski had no response from him
certainly this outcome was one that was
contemplated as being
entirely plausible it was an important
verdict for autism advocates
many outraged that autism spectrum
disorder was used as a defense
in terms of the erroneous perception
that having autism
is uh is is somehow akin to criminality
in terms of lack of capacity to make a
judgment
and and that's just wrong eight of the
ten people rammed and killed that day
were women
and marie d'amico's family started a
foundation in her name
as it relates to having women and
children live free of violence i think
i think it's a big step forward for us a
harrowing chapter in the city's history
also brings recollections of the heroes
that day the police and other first
responders
and the ordinary citizens who helped and
for those who suffered most
today brings some measure of
satisfaction i
probably will sleep tonight for the
first time in a while
eric sorensen global news toronto
the judge today made a point of naming
the people she calls the true heroes of
the day
they include toronto police constable
ken lamb constable lamb was the officer
who single-handedly confronted the
perpetrator after the van stopped
lam said afterwards he was just doing
his job but it was his composure and
professionalism that made headlines
around the world this is how it played
out
constable lamb shouts at the suspect to
get down
he is pointing something that looks like
a gun
and twice gestures as if he's pulling
something from his pocket
watch constable lamb react he calmly
walks to his cruiser
and turns off the siren the siren now
silent
he advances gun drawn then listen
to this exchange
constable lamb does not shoot even when
the suspect advances
trying to provoke him to open fire in
the end the man drops what he's holding
and gives up without a single shot fired
police forces around the world took note
of how constable lamb
de-escalated that tense situation and
it's considered a great
teaching tool now to ottawa and some
contradictory evidence at a defense
committee hearing examining allegations
of
inappropriate behavior by former chief
of the defense staff general jonathan
vance
a key question is what did defense
minister harjit sajin
know and when our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson broke this story
about the allegations against
vance and mercedes a former military
ombudsman appeared before the committee
today what did he say
well donna he says that he approached
the minister of national defense with
serious allegations of sexual misconduct
against the former chief of the defense
staff general jonathan vance
three years ago on march 1st of 2018.
he says that he was so concerned by what
he saw
he thought the minister should know but
listen as he describes to what the
minister
refused to accept as what he called
incontrovertible and concrete evidence
of that sexual misconduct i reached into
my pocket to show them the evidence i
was holding and he pushed back from the
table
said no and i don't think we exchanged
another word
i did offer to shake his hand at the end
of the meeting and said please
do get back to me with some advice to
tell me what i should do with this
donna minister sajin is a former
homicide investigator and police officer
so the news that he pushed back from the
table as the former ombudsman alleges
and refused to look at this evidence is
significant it also contradicts what the
minister is publicly said about becoming
aware of these allegations in the press
global news is aware of the evidence
that was in that envelope according to
multiple sources
it was the email chain we previously
reported between the previous chief of
the defense staff
and a then corporal propositioning her
allegedly to go to a clothing optional
beach
now when we look at all of this the
question is what more could have been
done
and the ombudsman says the defense
minister didn't do nearly enough
in his opinion here's what he had to say
about that
this was tossed like a hot potato i
think there were
a multitude of options available uh
discussion
the minister could have met with the
victim that may have been a possibility
the victim may have filed a formal
complaint
he i'm sure had more options than i had
mercedes what does this mean then for
the defense minister and for the prime
minister
well people are questioning whether he
can stay on if a government that
presents itself is feminist and saying
we believe women refuse to look
at somebody's allegations in that
envelope and refuse to to actually have
a look at them and do something although
he did email the privy council office
that was it we asked the prime
minister's office tonight if they still
have confidence in the minister
and this is what they said of course the
prime minister has confidence in the
minister we also asked minister sajin's
office about this just before we went to
air
they got back to us saying that he
disagrees with parts of the testimony at
committee
and that he was shocked as everyone else
was when those allegations became public
last month
through global news donna all right
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thank you
canada got another boost today to the
cobit 19
vaccine supply
five days after health canada approved
it for use the first doses of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine are on canadian soil
five hundred thousand doses arrived
early this morning from the serum
institute of india
with that now added to the vaccine
arsenal the government says it is on
track to exceed its target of 6 million
doses by the end of this month
and the prime minister said today the
promised target of getting everyone in
canada vaccinated by the end of
september
could be moved up we're seeing some of
the science shift some
proposals put forward which are very
very interesting which could
result in rapid or timelines it's
possible those timelines move forward
but we're going to base those decisions
on on the science
there is a major development tonight on
the official guidance over delaying
giving the second dose the national
advisory committee on immunizations has
now approved a plan to delay
the second dose by four months so more
people can get at least
one dose sooner the committee said
evidence from the last two months shows
there is a high level of protection
after the first dose and because of
limited supply right now regions
should get the first dose to as many
people as possible many provinces
including bc manitoba quebec and
newfoundland and labrador
have already adopted the plan even with
the promising vaccine news the
government warns it is
still too soon to let up on public
health restrictions
and support for struggling businesses it
is extending the canada emergency wage
subsidy and the canada emergency
rent subsidy until june that extension
is expected to cost an additional 16
billion dollars
well after months of tough restrictions
there is some relief in sight for people
in quebec
the premier says more parts of that
province will move from
the red alert level to orange next
monday that means the start of the
curfew will be pushed to 9 30 p.m
instead of 8 p.m
and restaurants can reopen with strict
limits in place the changes will not
apply though to the greater montreal
region
the premier says it will remain in the
red zone for now
in the u.s president biden now says
there will be enough vaccine for all
american adults to get it
by the end of may and some governors are
acting as if the pandemic
is over lifting restrictions and ending
mass mandates
even though the u.s centers for disease
control warns it is too early to be so
confident
jackson proskow reports
life looks back to normal in texas i'm
excited
like i'm excited not to have the mask on
the governor suddenly lifted the state's
mask mandate
and told businesses they can reopen
fully it is now time
to open texas 100 percent
and yet texas continues to average more
than 7 500 new cases per
day every one of those worrying virus
variants is circulating there
the lone star state is at the back of
the pack for vaccinations
48th out of 50. epidemiologists are
rattled
i think it's important for people to
realize that the the virus is still out
there at pretty high levels
and there's still a risk at getting
infected and causing
a surge of a third wave good afternoon
but mississippi has followed suit
and dozens of other states are starting
to loosen restrictions too
the last thing we need is neanderthal
thinking that in the meantime
everything's fine take
off your mask forget it it still
matters with thousands of americans
still dying every day
the centers for disease control warns
there are troubling signs
cases have declined from their winter
peak but they're still
high and rising again the b117
hyper transmissible variant looms ready
to hijack our successes to date
the next month will prove critical as
those virus variants become
dominant and as tens of millions of
americans are vaccinated
a race against time where there's bad
news there's also good
the biden administration has announced
that it will have enough vaccine
available for every american by the end
of may that's two full months ahead of
schedule
leading to the possibility of a summer
in the u.s that not only looks normal
but actually is donna hi i'm jackson
frosco in washington thanks
china's ambassador to canada gave a rare
press conference today in ottawa made
a lot of bold claims he talked about the
detention of the two michaels as well as
reports of genocide being committed
against muslim uighurs in the country
our chief political correspondent david
aiken reports on what the ambassador
said and the reaction china has secured
a complete
victory in the fight against poverty
that was just one of several incredulous
statements made by chinese ambassador
kong woo during an hour-long video press
conference wednesday
he would make more incredible claims
saying for example
that the arrest of the two michaels and
other canadians was
not in retaliation for the arrest of
chinese telecom
executive mong wong zhou there's no
connection
between these cases they are totally
different
in nature nonsense says canada's prime
minister
no it is obvious that the two michaels
were arrested on trumped-up national
security charges
chinese officials at the time were very
clear that they absolutely
were connected as as a frame as for the
vast region in northwest china known as
xinjiang
canada's parliament has concluded china
is engaging in a genocide
to destroy the 20 million muslim uighurs
who live in that region
but kong said everyone there is living
what he called
a happy life allegations of genocide and
the forced labor in xinjiang
are the lies of the century trudeau was
not buying that line either
we have uh and will continue to take
very seriously the very credible reports
of human rights abuses in
xinjiang in china perpetrated against
the uyghurs by the chinese state
there are significant concerns
being expressed all around the world
ambassador kong's goal seemed clear
to tell canadians that canada is
perpetuating lies about china
in fact canada's prime minister its
parliament and its allies including the
united states say
that when it comes to the two michaels
case or the uyghur genocide
it is china spreading falsehoods and
lies
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thanks
it's a seller's dream coming up why
homes are going like hotcakes in two of
canada's
priciest real estate markets plus
the deadliest day yet in myanmar's
protests against the military coup
there has been lots of economic pain
during this pandemic but what has
continued to grow are house prices in
some of canada's biggest cities
robin gill looks at what's fueling
canada's two hottest real estate markets
a vancouver condo listed at just under
nine hundred thousand dollars
sold in six days jason feinstein was the
listing agent
my phone was ringing off the hook i
probably had about 65 private showings
and then that turned into
15 offers it sold over asking
sanity seems to be prevailing despite
bidding wars
collect gerber with vancouver's real
estate board says the prices
aren't going to skyrocket yes of course
over time they will
go up but double digit increases
not on the calendar in february there
was a 73.3 percent
increase in home sales in vancouver
compared to 2020
the benchmark or median price for homes
is just over
a million dollars that's a 6.8
increase over a year ago low interest
rates
more money in the bank and short supply
all factors driving the market
but economist brian yu doesn't think
it'll last
any growth of this type of nature is
sustainable i think that we are probably
hitting a little tipping point
in the greater toronto area it's a
similar real estate story
in february there was a 52.5 increase in
home sales
compared to 2020. the average price over
a million dollars
up 14.9 percent from a year ago
our baseline forecasters see about 10
percent growth in the average selling
price
uh for for 2021. we're actually you know
above that mark right now
on the whole we do expect to see
double-digit price growth in in home
prices this year in the gta
feinstein doesn't see the demand
diminishing in vancouver
which is too bad for his buyers it can
be pretty discouraging when
again you're going up against 14 other
offers what a difference
a year makes before the pandemic sales
were dropping
the economics of supply and demand are
clearly at play
in 2021 robin gill global news
vancouver flying blind ahead an
australian airline attempts to boost
domestic tourism
there was more bloodshed in the streets
of myanmar's biggest cities today
security forces killed at least 38
people
protesting the military coup the
deadliest day since the military seized
control of the country early last month
the escalating crackdowns aren't
deterring the demonstrators
they are demanding democracy be restored
and for leader aung
suchi to be released from detention
australian airline qantas has come up
with a novel way to encourage people to
get on board and
travel within the country starting
tomorrow australians can book so-called
mystery flights you
buy a ticket board in brisbane sydney or
melbourne
and within two hours land somewhere you
just don't know where
until you get there qantas flew similar
mystery flights in the 1990s
and last year it offered a seven hour
sightseeing flight to nowhere
which sold out disaster averted next
the rescue mission off the coast of nova
scotia
there are few rescues more dangerous
than attempting to save people aboard a
sinking boat in the open ocean
at night in rough seas one of those
rescues happened off the coast of nova
scotia last night
it involved 31 fishermen rescue crews
from two countries
and some brave and steady work ross lord
has the story
the final four crew members are removed
from the atlantic destiny scallop
trawler
the end of a treacherous attempt to save
31 men
imagine you're playing darts except the
dart board is moving and you have to hit
bull's eyes and it's in the dark and
you're running around the entire time
instead of being stationary as you throw
the atlantic destiny was fishing about
220 kilometers
south of yarmouth nova scotia at
george's bank
at 8 20 p.m there was a distress call
from the trawler about a fire in the
engine room
a fire suppression system kicked in but
the boat lost power
waves were rolling to eight meters high
vicious winds
gusting to almost 100 kilometers an hour
the crew couldn't stop water from
flooding in
at one point there was even a flare-up
of the fire compounding an emergency
that could easily have ended in tragedy
canadian and american search and rescue
technicians teamed up
to save lives the hoisting area was
probably like a four by eight
section of the uh on the stern on the
right side on the starboard side
so it was uh it was a really tight spot
to be able to get the basket down you
just think about all the different
things that could happen
um you know we we we get a guy in the
basket and maybe we smash him into the
boat by accident or
the cable gets caught on something their
bravery inspired the survivors
the guys cheering like yeah you got
another one
so that that's it's good to hear from
them they're in good spirits and they're
definitely happy that they're off the
boat
safe with no injuries the atlantic
destiny on the other hand has sunk
its owners hope insurance will cover
that loss number one as
our people got off we can we can replace
a boat you can't replace lives
ross lord global news
amazing story that is global national
for this wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is sutton quebec
there are beautiful places all over this
country please email
us your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you